there is a Hogwarts Legacy secret you
only have one chance to see without
having to start a completely new
playthrough look at this point I'm sure
you already know about the gravestone
behind the gamekeeper's Hut the Chamber
of Secrets sync and the random dragon
flying about the world but today I'll
show you the secret you only have one
shot to notice as well as nine other
Easter eggs you don't want to miss
including one I haven't seen anyone
talking about yet that the developers at
Avalanche just teased in a recent live
stream first up that Easter egg that you
only have one shot at seeing per play
through well when Deputy had mistress
Matilda Weasley introduces you to the
room of requirement you'll need to first
pass through the room of hidden things
which is one form of the room of
requirement now thinking back to the
original Harry Potter series this is
actually where Voldemort hid one of his
horcruxes that Harry had to go and find
in Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
you'll only pass through this area one
time for each playthrough and you cannot
enter again there are a few interesting
things to find here like this letter
there's also a Jack In The Box that some
fans think is a reference to Severus
Snape but to me those are not the most
interesting objects here but first a
quick history lesson in Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets peeves drops a
Vanishing cabinet over filch's office
and damages it in the process later in
order of the Phoenix Fred and George
Weasley shove Montague of Dolores
umbridge's inquisitorial Squad into what
is most likely the very same Vanishing
cabinet being broken it doesn't work as
it's supposed to and Montague nearly
dies trying to apparate out it's
actually through Montague's experience
that Draco Malfoy figures out the broken
cabin and Hogwarts is linked to a
cabinet in Borgen and Berks and
ultimately if you know the story malfley
figures out how to repair the cabinet
with borgen's help and ends up sneaking
the Death Eaters directly inside
Hogwarts near the end of book six this
cabinet was moved to the room of hidden
things after Montague's traumatic
experience while it just so happens in
Hogwarts Legacy during your quick walk
through the room of hidden things you
can spot a Vanishing cabinet now if you
take a look at the screenshot from the
movie here there's no denying it is
meant to be a Vanishing cabinet but
could it be the very same one I suppose
the question would be just who took it
out before peeves decided to use it to
torment filch remember Hogwarts Legacy
takes place in the late 1800s so at some
point between the late 1800s and then
Harry's arrival at the school it needed
to make its way out of the room of
hidden things before making it back in
again and even if it's not meant to be
the exact same cabinet it's clearly a
nod to fans about what will happen all
those years later up next we have a
secret in hogsmead that I somehow missed
throughout my entire first 80 hours with
the game so if you go to the main square
area just across from honeydukes there's
a spot here where you'll often find
someone selling copies of the daily
profit during the daytime hours now
first up this is only there during the
daytime hours but in addition to that
it's also only there at certain times
throughout the year so whenever you find
this stand make sure you go approach the
stand and you'll actually be able to
take a look at the cover of the paper
not only that though you can also
interact with the paper and get a
close-up view for one of the day's main
stories what's even more interesting is
that even if you don't see a different
cover from what I could see they only
had about two or three covers but there
are actually quite a few different
stories that you can find and they
update each new day some of them even
build on stories from previous days
there's one about a Cornish wizard
arrested for breeding basilisks another
about someone cross-breeding a dragon
and a chicken which could be a nod to
Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix when Mr Weasley has a
conversation with a Ministry official
who's confiscated you guessed it a
fire-breathing chicken I won't spoil
them all here but one of my personal
favorites has to be the story of a
mother who believes her son has lost his
soul to a dementor there's even a line
here about her trying to give him
chocolate which of course is known
throughout the Wizarding World as a
short-term remedy to cheer someone up if
they've been in the presence of
Dementors now for her next secret here
did you know our defense against the
dark arts Professor Dina heckett isn't
nearly as old as she may first appear
you see you can actually learn even more
about the backstory for many of the
Hogwarts Legacy professors way more than
what you get in just the normal classes
all you have to do is return to their
classrooms after your designated class
times you'll have the option to speak
with them further to even ask more more
questions about their past and teaching
subject by talking to Professor heckett
after class you'll learn she worked as
an unspeakable in the department of
mysteries now being an unspeakable it's
no surprise she can't share too many
specifics about what she did during her
time in that role she does tell us
though that appearances can be deceiving
and that she was once wounded by time
itself now if you remember in Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix
there's a moment where Harry and his
friends discover a bell jar inside the
time room this jar has a tiny
hummingbird inside and as they watch it
transforms from an egg to fully grown
bird and back to an egg again of course
later on during the battle at the
department of mysteries one of
Voldemort's Death Eaters falls into the
Bell jar his head begins to rapidly
shift Through Time transforming from a
man's head to a baby's head that was one
extra little tip here you can learn even
more about most of the professors by
fully upgrading your alohomora spell
this will allow you to get inside any
room in Hogwarts including the private
study and living quarters for most of
these professors there you'll find
plenty of items and decorations to get a
sense of their style but in most of
these you'll even find letters written
to them by close friends or family
members now speaking of the boy who
lived himself there's also an absolutely
beautiful Easter egg for Harry Potter
and the Prisoner of Azkaban fans will no
doubt remember this iconic scene both
from the movies and from the books when
Harry and Hermione travel back in time
to save Buckbeak and Sirius Black in the
series this is where Harry casts a full
corporeal Patronus from across the lake
which of course takes the form of the
Stag now it just so happens you'll come
across this very same Lake in Hogwarts
Legacy inside the Forbidden Forest
there's actually a mission that will
take you here and when you approach the
lake there will be a stag around the
lake and your character will even
comment on the Stags that are there
something oddly solemn about this place
such Regal creatures stacked Avalanche
software has started doing their own
twitch live streams for the game and in
their most recent stream they teased an
Easter egg I haven't seen anyone else
talking about yet I was actually in the
chat trying to get them to answer this
question are there secrets we haven't
found yet of course peeves had to get in
the way and distract right after I asked
the question but eventually a little bit
later in that stream they approached
this vase here just outside the room of
requirement now if you make your way
over to this vase and adjust your camera
to see inside you'll notice there are
two bottles of butter beer here and what
they said is that this was a nod to
something that happens in the future not
necessarily something there in Hogwarts
Legacy so personally seeing how close
this is to the room of requirement I
believe it's actually a nod to a plot
point from Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire this plot Point featured Dobby
and winky the hell self if you remember
from that book winky actually got her
job in the Hogwarts kitchens after
getting sacked by Barney Crouch however
she was not happy about this and did not
enjoy her job at Hogwarts she ended up
going into a state of depression and
became addicted to butterbeer I know it
sounds kind of comical at first but it's
actually a very tragic story she just
remains addicted she basically becomes
an alcoholic with butterbeer now you may
say well this doesn't have alcohol and
it's true the popular Wizarding World
Beverage is said to contain very little
alcohol however it still proves to be
too much for a small house self
especially when consumed in large
quantities now for a time she actually
completely neglects her work at Hogwarts
many of the other house cells become
embarrassed by this by the fact that
she's basically just drinking butter
beer all the time Dobby of course being
the amazing awesome character that he is
tries to take care of her he even ends
up finding a bed from the room of
requirement where he can go and lay
winky whenever he finds her intoxicated
from consuming too much butter beer so
personally my guess is that these two
bottles of butter beer could very well
be a small knot to Dobby and how he ends
up caring for winky all those years
later as she struggles through her
butter beer addiction now that last one
I think it's pretty hard to find I mean
we had to have Avalanche tell us exactly
where to look but you know what it turns
out some of the most well-kept secrets
are hidden plane site on your way to the
dungeons you'll come across this
tapestry here now many of you probably
know about the secret room here but
there's a little bit more here now what
looks like a normal tapestry actually
contains a hidden entrance you can walk
straight through the K and you'll find
it was actually a hidden doorway all
along you can find a field guide page
here as well as a tapestry that tells
the story of a mother who was bitten and
turned into a werewolf but to reveal the
full story there's actually a special
use for the lumo spell so if you want to
see the story in the correct order
you'll start with the far left and look
at each tapestry exactly as is then when
you get to the very last tapestry get
right up close and cast lumos then turn
lumos off go to the next tapestry this
is going to be one step to your left now
and go all the way back to the original
tapestry to see the full story now stuff
like this I absolutely love I mean it
has me asking the question is it
possible there are other secrets in the
game still waiting to be discovered that
just require a certain spell in a very
specific location and also behaving in a
way that it doesn't normally behave I
mean I can't think of anywhere else in
the game where we see lumos do something
quite like this alright our next secret
involves one of the magical creatures in
Hogwarts Legacy now if you've managed to
breed unicorns yet in one of your room
of requirement vivariums you may have
been surprised to see that the Unicorn
is gold despite the coloration of its
parents now this is not some sort of
glitch or a rare type of unicorn it's
actually accurate to the original lore
of The Wizarding World According to
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
the companion book that is not the movie
of the same name unicorn foals were born
gold instead of white silver or gray
they actually remain gold until they're
about two years old when they begin
turning silver by four they'll have
their horn and then by seven they're
considered fully grown and will be Pure
White in coloration in Hogwarts Legacy
it seems that newborn creatures bred in
the vivariums will remain in that state
and will not grow into adults so once
you have that gold unicorn you'll get to
keep the little baby forever now given
Hogwarts legacies late 1800s time frame
it set back far enough that many of the
iconic Wizards in which as we know from
the original series are not present in
the game sure you'll notice the house
goes like nearly headless Nick and of
course peeves the Poltergeist makes
frequent appearances throughout but
there's one witch that appeared on a
chocolate frog card in the original
Harry Potter video games sakurisa
tugwood makes an appearance in Hogwarts
Legacy both as a student wandering the
halls but also in a more prominent role
with the spot removal quest after
talking with her outside dog Wheaton
death cap you'll learn she's been
experimenting with a new beauty cream
she's run out of the key ingredient buba
tuber plus that's right you heard me
correctly and just so happened she needs
our help to find more it's a simple
Quest but still a really fun nod for
fans considering that tugwood would go
on to having her likeness appear on a
famous witch card all due to her
discovery of the pimple curing
properties of Buba tuber pus now for our
next one I actually had the incredible
privilege to meet game director Alan 2
in person back at a pre-release event
before the launch of the game when he
was talking with us he teased a fun
little secret that involves the
potential for special interactions based
on the appearance of the gear you're
wearing so far fans have already
discovered a few different dialogue
options for the pajamas in the game
shameful go back to your dorm and change
into your school robes immediately but
I'm still trying others I mean surely
there has to be one when you're dressed
as a knight right don't you think have
you guys found any others if you have
let me know in the comments below and
I'll try to test it out myself in our
next little secret here involves one of
the most powerful late game spells and
that is the transformation spell
especially if you use a talent point to
upgrade it this spell will let you
transform enemies in battle into an
explosive barrel and then use the
ancient magic throw to send that Barrel
flying back at another enemy but like
lumos earlier the transform spell also
has an extra function in that it can
transform many of the animals you see
throughout the world of Hogwarts Legacy
I know right blew me away too now don't
let the fact that you can't lock on fool
you I always have to use the left
trigger for help with targeting the
animal now there are some animals I have
not seen this work on but the majority
of them it will work on including fish
now the first time I discovered this I
thought that's it that's where it ends
but if you keep going sometimes you may
actually get the animal to transform
into coins I have no idea what triggers
this if there's a secret to it who knows
maybe it's just a bug but the coins
definitely don't happen too often when I
was testing this out so it very well
could just be a random but intended
Easter egg that transformation spell is
just one of the many incredible spells
in Hogwarts Legacy I actually ranked
every spell in the game so if you want
to see where it ranks on the list check
out the video on the right side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon